Цей звук сирен знає кожен українець.
Це означає – пора йти в безпечне місце під землею.
Коли почалося повномасштабне вторгнення, шукати прихистку під час тривог
– для підприємств означало припинення роботи.
Та рік потому виробництво на цьому металургійному заводі продовжує працювати незважаючи ні на що.
Завдяки цьому імпровізованому пункту управління люди тут,
у бомбосховищі, можуть підтримувати автономну роботу машин.
Наші хлопці зуміли за місяць впровадити систему дистанційного керування
завантаженням ось цих бункерів, щоб повністю виключити людський фактор.
Таким чином з початку квітня минулого року ми вже працюємо під час повітряних тривог
в автоматичному режимі. Персонал йде у захисну споруду,
там вмикається система дистанційного керування
і ми можемо звідти керувати завантаженням бункерів та обпалювальною машиною.
Бункер забезпечений усім необхідним: їжею, водою, інтернетом та генераторами.
Керівник показує запаси.
У разі потреби, каже він, вони могли б прожити на цих продуктах кілька днів або навіть тижнів.
І хоч цей завод не постраждав, ризики все ще реальні
– російські війська досі знаходяться менше ніж за 100 км від нього.
Під час війни нехтувати цим не можна.
Ніхто не знає, що буде завтра.
Вони мають бути у нас підготовлені, функціональні та забезпечені запасами.
І дай Боже, щоб нам це не знадобилося.
Але іншим українським компаніям пощастило менше.
Дві російські ракети – з різницею у кілька днів
– влучили у це підприємство в Дніпрі, вбивши двох людей.
Якби перший удар не припав на вихідні, ця цифра, ймовірно, була б набагато вищою.
Це лотерея. Ракета може прилетіти в будь-який час,
у будь-яке місце, у будь-який будинок чи будь-яке приміщення.
Я тут вперше, бачив лише фотографії.
Я не хотів приїжджати, бо пам’ятаю техніку, зусилля, які ми витратили на все це.
Ось так це виглядає, коли на твій завод приходить "русский мир".
Через вибухи конструкції отримали стільки пошкоджень,
що ними більше неможливо користуватися. Тільки зносити.
А це ще одна фабрика В’ячеслава.
Вона все ще працює, але бореться з наслідками російських атак на енергосистему України.
Тут виготовляють преси для промисловості та обладнання для машинобудування.
Останні кілька місяців, коли звучить повітряна тривога,
енергетична компанія вимикає всю електрику. Це буває непередбачувано.
Щоразу, коли це відбувається, ми втрачаємо близько 40-50 тисяч євро за одну хвилину.
Матеріал всередині не може втрачати температуру.
Коли він втрачає температуру, він тріскається і ламається.
Та генератори допомагають у роботі.
Тепер працівники можуть запобігти неконтрольованим відключенням,
вигравши час для подачі природного газу, який стабілізує температуру до відновлення електроенергії.
Якщо раніше у них випадали цілі дні виробництва щоразу,
коли вимикалася електроенергія, то тепер це – лічені години.
Та електроенергія – не єдина проблема, з якою вони мають справу.
Українські фірми, які працюють незважаючи ні на що,
все частіше зіштовхуються з тим, що багато клієнтів у Європі
не хочуть з ними співпрацювати.
Вони бояться, що війна завадить їхнім
українським постачальникам доставляти товари.
Звичайно, всі втомлені та виснажені.
Іноді їм хочеться заплющити очі і уявити, що це все лише поганий сон.
Але ми не заплющуємо очі та продовжуємо боротися.
Усі борються на своєму місці. Моя робота полягає в тому,
щоб переконатися, що заводи працюють і люди отримують зарплати.
А я можу допомогти бійцям, купити спорядження.
Зараз все, що ми могли реінвестувати, ми витрачаємо на закупівлю безпілотників,
машин, спеціального обладнання.
Крім того, через повномасштабне вторгнення поменшало й клієнтів усередині країни.
У нас було багато клієнтів з Маріуполя,
тому що у Маріуполі були великі заводи і машинобудування.
Ще один наш продукт – спеціальні помпи,
які використовуються на великих заводах.
Це було 60% наших продажів у цьому регіоні.
Тому зараз ми шукаємо нові ринки збуту.
Спочатку в Україні ми виробляли цю продукцію для багатьох портів
і для багатьох великих заводів.
Тепер попит з Маріуполя нульовий.
Попит з боку портів Чорноморського регіону десь 20% у порівнянні з довоєнним часом.
Але не кожен бізнес може впоратися з такими ударами, як цей.
В’ячеслав розповідає, що щонайменше чверть його конкурентів уже збанкрутували.
І банкрутства продовжуються.
За словами керівника військової адміністрації Кривого Рогу Олександра Вілкула,
через блокаду Росією українських портів великі гірничо-металургійні підприємства
працюють на мінімум можливостей.
Великі підприємства металургійного комплексу,
гірничого комплексу зараз працюють на 10-20% реально.
Задля того, щоб працювала важка промисловість,
нам треба доступ до чорноморських портів.
Тобто до можливості експортувати продукцію.
Електроенергія – це проблема. Але головна проблема – це порти, це експорт.
Зараз там працює лише зерновий коридор, а інші види продукції там вивозити неможливо.
Тому, звичайно, цей продукт ніхто не виготовляє і підприємства працюють на 10-20%.
Попри всю стійкість, економіка України все ще перебуває
у вільному падінні, через що країна та армія дедалі більше залежать від міжнародної підтримки.